hello
and welcome back to part three of cloud
computing e-learning course
by simply learn i hope you had a chance
to go through
the second part which was patterns of
cloud computing
if not i would advise you to go through
the same
as you would require the knowledge of
patents to understand amazon web
services
which is discussed in this part this
part is titled as
implement we will go through amazon web
services
one of the most popular infrastructures
as a service provider
we will look at some of the popular aws
offerings
and go through some interesting demos
let us proceed to the next slide and
discuss what will be covered
in the implement part of the day 2
session
the implement part of the day 2 session
covers the second volume of cloud in
practice
we will first study with the aws 101
which is a brief introduction into
services of aws
we will go deep into some of the popular
services under aws
and browse through demos around them
finally we'll end with some
understanding of use cases
where aws can help
let us start with the aws 101
in the next slide we'll understand about
amazon web services
what is aws firstly
aws is a set of infrastructure web
services
amazon has built a service layer over
virtualized infrastructure
that allows a consumer to provision
resources over the web
these infrastructure services are
exposed as
rest api or web services
the services span across server storage
database object store and many other
infrastructure components
secondly aws allows on-demand
infrastructure provisioning this means
that a consumer can request for new
resources
at any point of time based on the
requirement
on-demand capability allows consumers to
be flexible with the infrastructure and
design systems
that are adaptable to scale aws
also allows pay as you go pricing model
this is the third arsenal in the aws
sleeve
due to the scale at which aws operates
it can provide the cheapest per hour
pricing
amongst all is providers this model
allows a low entry barrier
for any type of consumer big or small
aws has provided a fine granulation of
its services
that has varied pricing attached to it
this means for each service there are
multiple denominations
for example